食べて
パピとゲームねええええ
こちらのメンバー皆さんと一緒にパペてパップゲートに現場よっていこうと思いますよ
願いしまーす
はいルール説明でございますパピ子といって誰かを指さすことで突然
ゲームが始まりますいつどこで誰から始めても構いませんパピコって指さされた人は
ピッピこの掛け声て次の誰が指差します
パン粉っていうか第ございます復帰こべっこ
cocco とパピプペポの順番でかけ声と一緒に次の人を指さしていきますでぱぴぷ
ぺ部が一周し
とピコと指差された人はポーズを取りながら何度やっても同じこと
ん
何度やっても同じことという決めぜりふ表に入ってさらに次の人にパンパックこと言っ
て指を刺しますすっぱりポーズを左右交互に繰り返しながら決めいセリフを言うことが
ポイントです
20目からはたんぱぴこりんピックロップんぶっこ県別府後
本ポップこというふうにかけ恋に変わり次の人どんどん指さしていきますで3周目は
パンパンパ
ぴこりんぴっく4週目はパンパンたんぱぷとピンピンピン picco
というふうに周回を重ねるごとに頭につける文字2が増えていくというゲームです
実際に行ったほうがやっぱりはわかりですね実際にやってみましょう
なんてっ
透けてるよはあああああ
ああああああ
確かべきこぴっこぴこ
秋子
ラングやって同じことあんぱんえっ
ブーバポランだよ pou dou dou
政府が
雑費こう鉄壁胡ぼんぼっこ
なんでやってもらおう33パっ子
ピンピンピッコぷんぷん put in ピット
ポンポンポポポン何であっても同じことパンパンパンパーティ子
ピンピンピンピッカーぷんぷんぷんぷく
全然線ペンとポンポンポンポポポン
ランド行ってもらうこと短パンタンタンぴ
ああああああ
では me
ん
以降1個で使う
ぽこ何度やっても同じことパピコ
ああああああああ
stare
学ラン母がなかったので今回はかけた人は抽選
爆発没入んですそれじゃあ
普通
スピードを上げていた
誰かっていうかトリコぜっこポキコ
何度やっても同じましょう蛋白と言ってきた
ブルードゥワンワンワンワンワンワンワンパンマン今に食ってローマヤッホーワンワン
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
楽しいですね
ピコンぴっこぴこぽっこ
何度やっても同じことぱんぱぴこりんぴっくぴぺっこ付ポンチョちゃんねってこんな
ちょっとパンパンパンッ
ピンッ
おっ
全然ピッカー
何度やっても同じことパンパンパンパックホ
ピンピン神秘とプンプン武器庫
ですポンポンポンポンファーを持った
ディーエヌエー
な子猫 pict すご
ペップとっ
ぽっこ何度やっても同じことぱんぱぴこ
インティとどんどこ減っていこう
ポンプぴこ何度やっても同じことぱんぱんパっこてぃんぴっぴこ2ぴこ転変的呼
ポンポンポスト何度やっても同じかと333
はぁっ
wh
相手方のぱぴぷぺぱぴこゲームでした8すごいみんなで楽しめるゲームので是非行って
みてくださっこべっくわー
ん
んをっ
って言うとろびこへ
ポキコ何度やっても同じことパパぴっぴこ
グッディ3 jr
ああああああ